nous les sapeurs-pompiers nous
intervenons assez souvent pour ce type
d'opération ce type d'intervention je ne
vais pas dire qu'il s'agit réellement
d'une zone dangereuse puisque nombreux
sont ceux qui entreprennent démarche qui
fréquentent ces lieux
mais bon ben ya des risques il y à des
risques tel qu'aujourd'hui bon je ne
m'avance pas je ne peux pas dire
exactement le pourquoi ça s'est produit
mais en tous les cas il ya des risques
tel qu'aujourd'hui il ya eu une chute de
2 personnes au niveau de la cascade la
première cascade et puis bon voilà ce
que ça a donné
le premier conseil à donner c'est ce que
la prudence vous savez en vrai en
général ce
enfin qu'ils sont victimes d'incidents
ce sont ceux qui entrent en confiance et
qui néglige un petit peu les règles de
sécurité
voilà donc le premier conseil s'il à la
prudence il faut premièrement de bonnes
chaussures et puis de la découverture et
puis bien sûr de l'eau si la morge
servir longue il faut de l'eau et se
renseigne et peut-être avant voilà
absolument se renseigner sur le bateau
lui-même
et puis prendre la météo
savoie également la météo comment
comment notre sens heureux